we love friston and I mean because
active inference is actually about
preferences it's you know CU an agent
expresses agency by um kind of like
adapting the environment to suit its
preferences or to kind of make the
environment like its preferences so
basically this is a theory of valtion
right and and act you know that what
what KL friston's talking about is where
do these goals come from where does the
valtion come from and and you spoke with
KL about that I think over several years
didn't you yep yep yeah Carl's been a
wonderful mentor of mine
um I honest like it's a funny story I
like one I didn't know this was a term
in Academia but there's the the reviewer
Lottery where you just get lucky and you
get a reviewer so the first paper I
submitted uh Carl fren was a reviewer on
which was just lucky and then he became
a mentor and and reviewed my book and
gave me lots of good feedback so yeah
he's an amazing uh person been a
wonderful mentor of mine um so yes so
okay so let's talk about granula versus
a Gran because I think the best theory
I've seen is friston's theory on this in
my mind it Bridges the gap between
internalism and externalism because it
is describing this kind of didactic
exchange to use that you know there are
certain High entropy words that only
friston uses so if I say didactic
exchange you know I'm and by the way if
you if you um just for the folks at home
if you read friston's papers there are
certain words so he says this licenses
something so you know if you see the
word licenses then friston wrote the
paper but
anyway Max Bennett's new book A Brief
History of intelligence why the
evolution of the brain holds the key to
the future of AI is really really good
and I recommend you read it the book
kicks off with a quote from Charles
Darwin from way back in 1859 and it's
about how psychology and understanding
the human mind was all about to change
big time the main Insight from Darwin
was this recognition that capabilities
get added by graduation almost as if
there was a cosmic optimization
algorithm being applied in the
background Bennett's book is a treasure
Trove of ideas and it covers five big
themes about how our brains evolved the
first one is steering and then
reinforcing so learning about what
happens to us you know like when you
touch something hot and you learn not to
do it again simulating when your brain
is like a personal VR headset constantly
creating scenarios about what might
happen next mentalizing figuring out
what's going on in the brains of other
people's heads and last but definitely
not least is speaking which is to say
our language now your brain is always
running these simulations or these make
believe scenarios about everything
whether you're remembering your last
birthday party or planning what you're
going to say in a job interview or just
experiencing whatever's happening right
now your brain kind of tricks you into
thinking it's all real but actually it's
making it all up so this whole thing is
pretty similar to how computer models
like chat GPT work they don't really
store specific paragraphs of text
instead they're always pasing together
new text based on patterns and context
anyway Bennett's book and our
conversation really made me think about
how Wild it is that so much of what we
see and remember or even plan isn't as
straightforward as we think what's
really interesting about about this book
Max is um you know obviously i' I've
read loads and loads of books in in the
space and there's you know people like
Hinton and Hawkins and damasio and
friston and I mean God you know even
like SU
and what's interesting is it's a bit
like the Blind Men in the elephant so
they've all got a completely different
story to tell and I think the magic that
you have pulled off with this book is
somehow you've woven it together into a
coherent story like what what do you
think about that you know and I didn't
come to it with the objective of writing
an academic book at all I came to it
from the objective I was just learning
on my own um and I just started building
this Corpus of notes um CU I was so
independently curious and I kind of
stumbled on this idea really for myself
of how do I make sense of all of these
disperate opinions um and really this
complete lack of information about how
the brain actually works uh Hawkins
spoke about this as well he said we've
got the Matrix inside our brains right
we're always just doing all of these
simulations of of future things and uh
we're using that to kind of help us
understand the world and you you get
this really interesting example of um
some of the features of the brain that
kind of lead you to believe that we are
basically living in a simulation and
it's almost like rather than perceiving
things we're testing if our simulation
is correct first sort of introspections
and Explorations into how perception
works in the human mind happened in the
late 19th century with all of these
explorations of visual illusions that
you see in pretty much every
Neuroscience textbook or book that you
open you probably seen examples of
triangles where you actually perceive a
triangle in a picture when there is in
fact no triangle
that clearly the brain observes the
presence of things even though they're
not actually there so we perceive a
triangle there we perceive a sphere we
perceive sort of a bar we perceive the
word editor when in fact if you actually
examine that the word e is not there
that always seems very vague I'm I'm
kind of experiencing it but it feels
like the experience is over there and
and I'm over here whereas right now I'm
having a conversation with you and
everything is is in 4D Cinema color and
an hour ago I was kind of simulating me
having this conversation with you and
that was also a little bit distant and
not quite as bright as this conversation
right now so you know just from a
phenomenology point of view or maybe
from a coherence point of view what's
the difference I don't think we know I
think that's a really great question
which is why is it the case that um real
sensory input feels so much richer than
closing our eyes and imagining things um
and and is it perhaps is it a feature or
a bug is part of the feature somehow
ensuring the fact that we don't confuse
the two um you know is hallucination
people who hallucinate who do experience
it perhaps in the same 4D color is the
flaw that um they're rendering something
and they can't tell the difference would
you would you think that intelligence is
quite specialized yeah I would I would
put myself in the Yan laon camp on this
where I don't think uh there is a
general intelligence I mean I've gone
around talked to so many people in the
space ask for a definition of AGI the
smartest people in the world keep giving
me different answers so and I don't
think that's a coincidence I think it's
because we don't really know what we
mean by that term we know there's this
thing called human-like intelligence and
we know we're very interested in at
least recapitulating that in a machine
and then we can conceive of ways to ramp
that up it'd be nice to have a human
level intelligence that you know didn't
have uh certain types of biases well we
could probably tweak some parameters to
do that we'd like them to have better
memories we could probably tweak some
parameters to do that um but it's I'm
skeptical of the view that there's going
to be one General intelligence that does
all of these things because I think at
the end of the day there's going to be
certain tasks that we want these
entities to do and there's always going
to be Energy Efficiency uh speed
efficiency all these things that will be
gained by adding some inductive biases
adding some specialization into these
systems to do the tasks we want of them
Transformers are OB stens um intelligent
artifacts I mean some people even call
them Proto agis but cynically though you
could say Well they're just they're
basically a database lookup and they
don't have any agency they don't have
any creativity they only have
combinatorial creativity and and then
and then you kind of make the move of of
asking well isn't it it's a bit weird
it's a bit weird that that it's fooled
so many people it's it's apparently so
intelligent you know and it's just
capturing some snapshot of of a very
complex system the Subspace of our
language is actually um not that big and
and that's because language as an
organism has evolved to be learnable by
children there are clear fascinating
General I think uh clear amazing
generalizations that Transformers are
capable of I mean the fact that the
reason why this is so hard to measure
which is one of my critiques of sort of
the way this whole Transformer craze is
unfolded is part of what we mean by
intelligence is the distinction between
the training data and the test data in
other words can you perform a task in a
relatively new environment from where
you've been trained it's at least one of
the key dimensions on which we want to
measure intelligence and because the
training data is obscured it's very hard
to validate the difference between you
know the stochastic parrot critique
which is I'm asking you a really hard
question and you answered it well but I
have no idea if that's actually
literally a database lookup or I'm
asking you a really novel question and
clearly you learned some Concepts and
then presented something and came to a
really clever conclusion and it's really
hard to tell the difference of this
primarily because we don't know the
training data it I think it does shine a
lens on us that there are so many things
that we thought were intelligent that
maybe aren't right well this goes a
little bit to morx Paradox where you
know the things like we like to law
lawyers for being so smart and then all
of a sudden you know a Transformer beats
the bar exam and then it still can't
load a dishwasher right which is okay
the things that are so obvious for us
are actually part of what's so hard yeah
I I don't know whether you had the same
impression as me but I think when chat
GPT came out everyone was quite scared
people were talking about it automating
jobs and um but now I look on LinkedIn
and I can easily recognize chat GPT text
it's delving diving intricate you know
it's like Ted Talk type speech and I
feel like people are now starting to see
it for what it is you know it's like a a
cute toy but it's it's not really going
to be quite as revolutionary as everyone
thought but there are some real problems
with it kind of polluting the infosphere
it's it's cannibalizing these retrieval
search engines are cannibalizing the
actual search engine and and now the
models are kind of eating their own poop
and and training on on the output
gen